у них напали справи cipro тести на 2
зошит його обстріляли українські
бульбашки
за видами і в штабі ато стріляв із
граната мотив тоді як алібірних куна
мотив по притяг би дві сторони вигляд
водиться з броні вид лінії фронту врятувати
лихачі фіксує хіба що кістки
обстрілявши ended up радіус броні вигляд
водите в 1 годину ми з постригаємо ще потім
тебе зброя знака витоками всяку інші
види червоний і знову є на лінії злитий
мене
ми фіксуємо про на лінії зид на небо
готове до цих установок за кремом бачіли
два гради на та частини шиза словами та
врятувати лихачів стріляйте в районі
донецького аеропорту сторони конфлікту
званого трохи ось на одну в пару шині
мінських думала настей з біля криму
перемир'я
світ нижче ти великий пан та ласе в зоні
конфлікту у примор'ї
довіряти ні впевненим а я ставлю настя
у завтрашньому дню мені можна вірити цим
мінським домовленостям їх на цей
ремонт дотримується Європи але я боюся та
встану в цій команді відео з
постриг на території донецького
аеропорту то активному до зростання це
безпілотники на знайдеш конфліктний
ділянках між рідні врятувати лихачі
поважають тим це динозавр штаб їх ти мені
через електроні париж коди зоні
конфлікту не емісійних саме в них
tender love her presence in a moment
місії lbs єни з морем а ти більше
пунктів способі дружині на лінії вид на ньому
там ще на непідконтрольних українах
територіях нам треба чи допомагають це
mission hills of income штани
дня ми у б дві сторони завершив і адже
вид артилерії калібром менше 100
міліметрів новинку 15 кілометрів битві
не язик мене тепер на думку врятувати
лігачів холодно та контроль вати щипці
битви даного оружня не портали